welcome to this video playing
international massive ask a muskie the
log on Mozilla rich let's see the system
this is Serbia right yep now i have
looked this up let's see what happens
nims oh i guess or not know that the
Queens gambit exchanged exchange not
exchanged so let's see what line is
choosing the absolute main line maybe he
five okay that seems really early yeah
all night before I don't want to don't
want to face jab funnier the kind of
stuff that's possible but it's not so
bad the ideas 96 bishop h4 g6 now
getting this this this maneuver in with
them Knight to f5 or Bishop Dyer 5 i'm
not sure that it's really that great
here but okay okay i want to
try to play Bishop F to keep them keep
this on the board the bishop then push
for reform okay so keep it on the board
and then go for you for you should be
good on Bishop f5 I go Eve 495 the same
he might play c5 that's not go very well
with a five though still maybe that's
what you should do yeah I will play you
for basically no matter what almost I
need to think about efore de Fe for
knigu on I don't want to give up the
spaceship on f2 yeah and I'm not be
you're not going to play Bishop a6 here
right this looks really slow still if I
go reform okay there's this fits in in
any case so let's see no this was the
idea it was preparing c5 but hmm if I
take it how exactly are you avoiding
this loss of a porn like here i'm going
to take d5 player for at the end and win
win this bag yeah i guess black asus has
no way to avoid that really don't see
how I can just take the five and then go
a form
I mean he has he was so slow in his
development that something like that was
bound to happen um II for maybeee fire
and then take you five
here I even never a choice I can also
take with the pony by one but yes Bishop
f5 this does not look very attractive so
um probably we're going to take him okay
so he's got this this counter play
against the pawn interesting so should i
am rook t2i scan Bishop g5 maybe
p 1 is not not helping at all what's the
best way to play that I do I have to
play up to two yeah maybe I have to but
you can take on d5 yeah okay so have to
do one of those
Bishop g5 I have to play a four nothing
nothing else nothing terrible that I
need to do that but I was hoping that I
can avoid a move like that ok and now I
just go here right and if he takes I get
the night to defy they have night a for
coming and Bishop g5 I will get to wear
so this is the this is very convenient
now they also threaten to take on e6 m95
that's nice
so I can give checks here if I want but
it's a this is also good piling up on
the porn yeah want to want to be quick
here it's probably not the the simplest
way to do it
and a foursome a problem maybe he can
play Bishop age six and 94 and it's that
that was a bit more problematic of thing
so how to do this now I'm here to
dominate the night first and then go
from there
if I've for simple okay dumb yeah it
should slow in getting the bishop over
to be to before b6 and stuff like that
check coming to the six months I'm
working against us check no oh man what
am I doing here in the sky is not even
overstepping the time check check
check check black forfeits on time yeah
I'm winning again yeah I was I wasn't
really paying any attention to be honest
him because it was also winning yeah
that didn't didn't look any more but of
course he has really have one I just I
just have to play g3 and make sure that
drew k have one is is is of no substance
then you just just enter with the rook
and it wasn't this wasn't so
straightforward technically ok ok ok
this is this as possible but taking and
93 was maybe even simpler it was it was
always keeping a big edge picture g3 is
also good young there was there were
many many good good continuations but i
think i'm glad if I just you know just
able to keep keep the edge there always
always wore so it was quite ok I only
blundered this rook f1 move when I was
looking so much closely anymore ok
thanks for watching